Yeah.
Hey,
what's going on?
It's Bill Burr.
It's time for the Monday morning podcast for Monday,
March 25th,
2018 what's going on?
How are you?
Oh,
stop it.
Yeah.
Everything's gonna be fine.
Okay.
Shake it off.
What'd you think?
Bad stuff was only going to happen.
Other people every once in a while comes few neighborhood shake it off,
but smiling plus.
Um,
anyways,
uh oh.
Did I wake up mad this morning?
What a surprise.
What are unique emotion from the freckled country have come to know and love?
MMM.
By the way,
you know,
now that I went through all of that bullshit to get on fucking Instagram,
the fact that you have to follow 9,000 fucking people or you get to say you just
stared at the same photo every fucking day and it's just really like a,
it's like a mace.
You know,
you're on Twitter,
you just fucking on Twitter now.
You still have to follow people,
I guess.
Now I've got to fucking go on.
Ah,
I can't fucking follow all these fucking gay on dance.
My wife's telling me good.
I Yaron gs.
Follow all your friends and food.
Think of things you're interested in so I can just be another mouth breathing
dopes staring at my fucking phone.
I already,
I already stare at it too much.
Um,
you know,
I thought I was going to get on Instagram and all I was going to see his ass and
titties said I just not seeing it right.
It's probably cause I only followed Dean del Ray and Joe Rogan.
So what I see is,
uh,
what did I see us?
So Joe Rogan walking around holding a chicken with another 40 chickens following
him.
All right.
All these years I've known Joe Rogan.
I had no idea that he owned chickens.
You know,
it's causing me to reevaluate our entire friendship.
I mean,
I don't know why he would keep that from me.
Does he?
Does he think he can't trust me with that information?
That these are the kinds of things I'm going to ask him
the next time.
I think I've had them on here.
Okay.
I don't fucking know.
Anyways.
And,
and,
and Dean del Ray's in New York,
that's what I know.
That's all I know.
No whores,
no inspirational workout videos.
You know,
where some guys trying to inspire you to work out,
but he's really just wanted to take his shirt off.
You know what's funny about those fucking,
it's Instagram people is beyond the fact that they're doing that show,
the inspirational celebrity where they're just every day,
you know,
acting like they have life all figured out and now they're going to pass these
gems on to you.
Hey,
next time you're thinking outward,
look inward to find the real use.
So your truth can be you fucking sent to the stratosphere and shut the fuck up.
And the other one I love,
I love the celebrity fucking standing outside his private jet with this serious
look on his face.
How about a smile?
You fucking cunt
standard there,
yo.
This is how we do.
This is my Louis Vuitton luggage.
What a fucking moron.
Gotta Asshole by $5,000 fucking pieces of luggage so some asshole can throw it
in the bottom of a fucking United flight.
Yeah,
no,
I don't know.
You'd have to fly private for the rest of your life and watch your luggage.
Just going easy,
easy,
or you could just get a fucking bag that's designed to get the shit kicked out
of it.
You can keep all your fucking jewels inside of it.
Yeah.
Oh my God.
If I see one more cont do the photo shoot with all their cars and then there's
the fucking private jet in the background.
What went down?
What is that?
And you know,
just to fucking just put it under,
I'm rubbing it in your face that I have more money than you.
Don't fucking do that thing where I'm trying to inspire you to get to my level.
Okay.
Do you realize everything that has to be involved?
They're like,
you have to fucking call up the fucking airport.
Some poor bastard has to do that.
You have your cars.
It's not enough that you have your cars.
It's not enough that you're flying private.
It's not enough that your luggage costs more than what a lot of people make to
fucking teach kids in public schools.
You have to have all of that.
I mean,
how many fucking drivers do you need to get all your fucking cars out there?
Then you got to figure out what fucking outfit you're gonna wear.
I Dunno.
Anyways,
plowing ahead.
But that is the kind of shit that I want to see.
I actually kind of have this thing going on with,
with friends of mine where we just send each other all of those like photos.
Yeah.
That poor kid who died there,
the,
the humble brag guy.
He woulda had a fucking field day on Instagram.
Jesus Christ.
I mean,
that's why I kind of went on there.
I just didn't realize it was going to be that much work to try and find all of
those fucking photos because people would just send me them all the time and I
was like,
Jesus Christ,
I'm,
I'm really missing out not being on Instagram.
And then you get on there and I,
I followed Dean del Ray and Joe Rogan and my beautiful wife and that's it.
And Rogan and Dean del Rey,
or normal grounded human beings.
So it's just,
you know,
tell me who to follow.
Okay.
I do enough fucking promotional as other ones.
I just want to see,
I want to see that.
That's the Shit I want to see.
I want to see people that are pretending to inspire me,
but they're really just fucking,
you know,
they want to show me how much money they have or how great is shaped her.
And,
um,
I mean,
why can't everybody be down to Earth like me?
I'm sorry,
I'm just a self involved.
I'm just not as motivated in the gym.
Plus you,
it's fun.
Even if I got shredded,
I mean,
if I took my shirt off,
all people would say is like,
dude,
the fucking white.
You are.
Oh my God.
I bet.
What about Mike?
What about my eight pack abs?
Um,
nobody cares.
all right,
so let's get to my week here.
I went and I saw ministry live for the first time.
I saw them,
uh,
down at the,
the fuck is it?
[inaudible] the house of Blues in Anaheim.
And I was meeting some friends down there and they're like,
oh,
we're at the,
and we're at the Ramada my guy,
so I fuck with her at the bar.
So I walk into the Ramada,
go to the fucking bar.
There.
They,
uh,
there's nobody there.
Turns out I'm at the wrong Ramada.
Who knew there was more than one role model,
whatever the fuck it was,
wherever the hell it was going.
So anyways,
we ended up going over to the,
uh,
to the show and it was just,
it was awesome.
Live music was in always will be the shit.
And I got to see them,
uh,
basically play the entire album.
There are new album Amera can't KKK aunt,
um,
and Al Jourgensen as always,
just fucking crushing it,
fucking crushing it,
man.
You know,
there's front men and then there's front still has the passion,
Silky,
you know,
got the fucking crowd going.
You're looking around,
you know,
a lot of people like my age by the,
like the fucking fourth song,
there was a mosh pit.
I stayed clear of it.
I definitely stay clear of it,
but they got a bunch of,
uh,
I think they're on like a 25 city tour right now.
And they,
right,
they did a Anaheim and then Oxnard,
I don't know where they're off to now.
We promote a couple of their dates.
They're considered such a fucking awesome show.
Here we go.
Am I a man?
Is
three torr dates yet that Dah,
Dah,
Dah.
[inaudible] come on man.
Why is my Internet so fucking slow?
Yeah.
It'd be funny if they actually had it run at the same speed as your intellect
and you couldn't get mad anymore.
It's like,
well,
it's because I'm a fucking asshole.
I'm dumb.
All right.
They're going to be in Sacramento at the ace of spades.
Portland,
the Roseland theater.
Oh,
that's a beauty.
That's on Wednesday.
Thursday they're going to be in Vancouver at the vogue theater.
Saturday,
they're going to be an Edmonton.
All right.
And then when they go into end to April,
they're going to be in,
uh,
Montana,
Nebraska,
Chicago,
Illinois.
A couple of nights there.
Cincinnati,
grand rapids,
Michigan,
Indianapolis,
Toronto,
Mario,
when they're playing great places.
BOSTON,
April 17th,
um,
a couple of nights there.
Portland,
Maine,
Jesus,
they go going everywhere.
You got to catch them in.
That runs through
the fuck is,
it runs through the end of April as far as what they have here.
Um,
all right,
back to the podcast here.
So old freckles forgot that it was formula one season and unfortunately somebody
on Twitter said,
hey,
you excited for this weekend?
I was like,
Oh shit,
that's right.
And because it's now not on NBC sports,
the ESPN cons took it over and God knows they'll fuck it up somehow.
That's what I thought they were going to do.
I've got to admit,
I watched what I got of the race.
I thought they did a good job,
although I don't understand why we'll Buxton isn't there now they have like this
comedy team or some shit.
They got two people down there who then throw it over to another guy.
You think ESPN would try to save money
and not fucking hire three people for the job?
That one guy was doing outstandingly since I've been watching,
but a,
I don't run this shit.
So anyways,
I fucking go on and my cable box and I go to record the race and I don't know
what happened.
All I recorded was the pregame,
which ended up getting me like the first 10 laps of the race.
So I missed the fucking race.
Uh,
but then I went on and I read all about it.
First thing that I noticed was the new,
the uh,
Jesus Christ.
I'm stuttering here,
their new design of the,
uh,
the cocktail.
I'm like,
what the fuck is that thing that's like in the driver's line of sight.
And they got this new halo thing that they got going on.
Um,
I guess for a years since like 2010 or 11,
they'd been trying to figure out,
you know,
cause it's the open cockpit,
people smashing into walls,
tires and bolts go fly in.
These guys that drive in,
you know,
upwards of a hundred fucking 80 miles an hour.
You get hit with a scroll,
you know,
could go right through your helmet.
India fucking head.
I don't know.
They've been trying to figure out how to protect them,
you know,
and then all everybody in the crowd's like,
well hey man,
don't put it like make it look like a fighter jet man where you're like is,
he's always been open cockpit man.
So everybody in the crowd,
you know,
they want to see,
it's like,
listen,
if we're going to sit here along this fucking fence in,
at any point,
a washer can come flying off the car,
go through my eye socket and into the back of my brain,
me,
at least you can do is with your fucking almant driver out in an open cockpit.
So they decided
to come up with this new design.
Uh,
the halo car pick design,
which is supposed to,
uh,
looks like a giant piece of plastic to me.
It's probably made out of carbon fiber.
Um,
but if a deli that will stop a,
a tire from smashing you in the fucking head and killing you,
nobody wants that.
Right?
I don't think so.
So anyways,
I saw at the beginning of the race and as always,
Lewis Hamilton got the pole position.
It help.
Yeah.
And uh,
the race starts and he gets to the first corner first.
So obviously he's going to win the fucking race.
That's how it works.
And even one of the announcers stupidly said,
well,
you know,
history has shown that whoever wins the first race of the year usually goes on
to win the championship.
And I don't know if that was a comment on how much lack of fucking passing there
is or the fact that basically Mercedes and Ferrari have such superior engines
that you don't,
nobody else can compete with them.
You know,
I mean,
I know other teams like the American team Haas has Ferrari engines,
but that's like this shit one.
Like they get the z 28 engine,
we get the fucking rally sport,
um,
just for white trash people from the 70s.
Um,
so anyways,
uh,
I guess what happened,
Sebastian Vettel one,
the uh,
on the Australian Grand Prix for Ferrari who went back to the Ferrari red or I
guess less white in their car.
The car's definitely look different,
looked like at different color red.
And I was like,
there's no way that there's like a specific read the Ferrari has to be,
but it turns out they just had less white in the car this year.
Uh,
they went on to win it because,
um,
their Mercedes team I guess fucked up where,
uh,
Lewis Hamilton went into Pitt.
They thought they had enough space between the fucking second place and first
place he was going to get out of the pit first or something like that.
I don't know.
Oh No,
he was out on the track.
I just saw the highlight.
I don't fucking know.
And they screwed up,
but you know,
it's fucked up.
They blame their software.
So it's just like,
is there any sort of like,
I dunno,
racing going on.
So they got some computers looking where the fucking Sebastian Vettel's car is
in the pit and wow.
How fast they have to be going.
What tar though?
The computer figures all of that out.
You got an APP and evidently the APP shit the bed and uh,
that'll got out first.
You know,
Hamilton,
he's always fucking sell was
[inaudible] you right.
I love Hamilton,
but he gets so fucking,
he go,
he just starts bleeding and whenever you fucking losers.
Um,
I remember last year something happened in qualifying and then he just sat in
his car for like fucking maybe when,
when when you were a kid and he got mad at your parents or whatever and they got
out of the car,
went in the house.
You're trying to make a point.
You just sat in the car in the driveway.
They didn't give a shit to let Greg how's,
we'll be quiet.
But that's your fucking complainant ass in here.
Um,
so he ended up winning Ferrari one.
Sebastian Vettel came in first,
uh,
a soaking Lewis Hamilton came in second Kimmy Reagan and eight and drive anybody
off the track came in third.
And,
uh,
Ricky Ricardo,
Daniel Ricardo came in,
uh,
the hometown favorite Cayman in fourth place.
And what's his face?
Valtteri bolt.
Haas,
I guess he crashed,
you're in qualifying and was given us five spot penalty for,
uh,
cause he changed a gearbox.
He started in 15th and then ended up finishing eighth.
But I think the real big story was how well the USA team with their [inaudible]
fucking Ferrari engine,
that Ferrari threw up in their back dumpster,
um,
was fucking killing it in the beginning.
We were like in fourth and sixth place at one point.
The part of the only part of the race that I saw.
And then,
uh,
I got all excited,
you know,
to look up to see where we finished.
We finished 19th and 20th with two,
not one,
but two did not finish
I guess.
Evidentaly uh,
we know how to take the tire off,
but we don't know how to put it back on
twice in the same race.
One of the hottest cars went in.
Yeah.
To get the tire change their way.
They put the fuck guitars back.
God,
three out of four were on,
but one wasn't.
They did that the first time and then the fucking mechanical screwed it up was
hilarious.
They cut to the cut to the,
uh,
the pit team and he just walked out of the camera shop.
Why?
Then he went into the bathroom and closed the door and probably throw up that he
cost his team,
one of the cars,
you know,
and then the fucking,
then they turned around and they did it again.
But uh,
they're keeping that Chin up there saying,
you know what?
Well A,
you know,
if,
uh,
you know,
just stick.
What would happen if we actually put the bolts back on?
I'll tell you if Rory Mercedes better look out because Ya,
we're going to be practicing how to take a tire on and off for when we get that
down.
I'm telling you things are going to be real shook up in the a four to six
positions this year.
Yeah.
Boy,
you know what it is.
We're Americans.
We don't give a shit.
Okay.
Cause this,
this whole fucking Duh left turns and right turns the we have land over here.
Yeah.
Fucking assholes in Europe and everywhere else around the world.
You're all fucking over populated,
driving around fucking on an old cow paths.
Um,
that's all I got.
What else can I do?
What do you do when you completely screw up?
You know what you do,
you make fun of the rest of the world.
That's exactly what you do.
Alright,
let's get into some happier American news.
The Boston Bruins,
once again were down.
They were down two to nothing to
the Goddamn Dallas Stars.
So down in fucking Dallas now they used to be the Minnesota north stars.
Okay.
And it was an eclectic group of incredibly normal looking people in the crowd.
And,
and the Minnesota people,
nice people,
the kind of people you say hello to,
or if you Philly fan,
she throw full beers at right.
Then they moved down to fucking Dallas.
Okay.
The fake titty capitol of the world.
Yeah.
All right.
You know,
you know silicone valley out there where they do all the fucking computer shit,
you know,
an Apple's big fucking all look around building with the forest in the middle of
it.
Um,
that's where all the computers shit happens down in Hollywood's where all the
movies get made out in Arizona's where they,
they don't want to celebrate Martin Luther King Day
New Mexico's where they shop breaking bad.
And then you get out to Dallas,
Texas.
Okay.
And you basically you have Dealey plaza and you have fake titties that is
fucking Dallas.
And then you have a bunch of shiny four door pickup trucks that has never seen a
day of blue collar work driving around out there.
I don't know why.
I Dunno.
Why you taking,
they get themselves Cadillac.
Um,
everybody's acting like they got a ranch.
anyways,
we went down,
then we played them and we were down two to nothing and we score three goals in
the third fucking period.
It was just,
and of course I missed the game cause I got the kid now I was at a,
I was at a birthday party,
a great birthday party,
went out to a fucking farm and all of that had an awesome time.
But I didn't get to see the game.
And I saw Tim shallows,
fucking filthy shorthand for nice feed from Brad Marshawn,
a pasta knock at the game winner.
And it seems even though you know Theresa Persia,
Ron's out with a broken foot.
I Dunno if Chara his back last game I saw he fell the way I used to fall when I
was public at like a public skating rink.
You know what I mean?
Will you try to stop and then you catch an edge and all of a sudden you go like
headfirst,
do a face plant before the board's mercifully stopped.
You usually knocked down like a five year old trying to learn how to figure
skate.
Uh,
I'm trying to say we have a lot of injuries,
but we're still winning.
Uh,
the Celtics on the other hand,
Kyrie Irving is going to be out three to six weeks.
Sports Illustrated's website is telling me I don't need to panic.
Toronto's going to get the number one seed and we're probably going to play some
shit bomb fucking team and he'll be back by the end of it.
I don't fucking know.
Uh,
I think Toronto's will come pretty strong.
It's going to be obviously Toronto,
Cleveland.
When you think,
when you think and can Lebron put his fucking team on back once again.
Okay.
And get to the finals again while the entire basketball world shits on them and
says how much he's an asshole.
Now mind you,
I've never seen a guy achieve more and get more shit.
I just don't get it.
What more does he have to do?
All right.
He took his talents to south beach.
He won two championships on a pile on team.
But Daddy,
he went back to Cleveland,
put the fucking team on his back
and beat the Golden State Warriors.
Right.
Right there.
It should have been over.
It was over for Steve Young when he beat the fucking San Diego chargers.
Okay.
He,
whew.
Uh,
huge.
Was it chuck Humphreys?
You chump freeze Chuck Humphreys.
I don't remember.
Be That fucking team.
One of the most boring super bowls there ever was 49 is went out and they had
fucking white pants on and shit.
MMM.
And then the monkey's been off his back and nobody ever fucking questioned him
again.
Ever questioned him again.
Even after fucking spygate when he said the Patriots should give up their three
fucking super bowl titles,
you know,
fucking guys on TV,
he's in hall of fame player.
He didn't realize that that was a brand new rule and the Patriots weren't
guilty,
but it was only illegal for one gate.
Nobody gave him shit yet.
They still give Lebron Shit.
Why is that?
Why do you think that is?
Is it because Steve Young is a fucking more,
um,
I have no idea.
Anyway,
so I went to this birthday party,
a two year old's birthday parties from friends of ours and there was this,
uh,
went out to the speaking ranches.
We went out to this farm way the fuck out towards Oxnard came a Rio.
MMM.
It was awesome.
It's part of,
you know,
part of Los Angeles.
I very rarely go to,
I fly over it,
but I never fucking actually went out there.
It was absolutely beautiful out there,
past the theme you valley and they had all like these animals and stuff.
They're big animal farm and I realized that I am a big fan of Al packers.
You know,
there was this brown one just with these giant fucking brown eyes just looking
at you.
A little weird little wema admittedly a little weird,
you know,
they kind of look like llamas.
They like better looking llamas,
you know?
Um,
pot belly pig,
which I never realized when people say I go,
you know,
you've got a pot belly.
What an insult that is.
I mean,
these things were fat fucks that belly was Lee was like on the ground.
MMM.
They just like,
they just did fucking pigs.
I mean,
pigs really,
our pigs,
they always talk about how smart they are and that type of stuff.
I think the level that they eat in the fact that they roll around in their own
shit,
it's just really hard to see the intelligence.
You know what I mean?
I mean,
I think a lot of fat people get treated the same way.
Do you think if Albert Einstein was a fat fuck,
like
I dunno,
rolling around in his own shit.
I mean,
I don't think we win World War II.
What do you guys think?
You care to comment?
Would you like to write into the podcast about that one?
Um,
I'm just filibustering here.
I got to get this shit done cause I got all kinds of stuff to do today and I'm
waiting for my advertising and my questions to come in and God dammit,
Oh,
the reads is sent.
Oh Shit,
everything's fucking here.
Ready to go.
I love it.
All right,
let's download these goddamn things.
Um,
so anyways,
we were at where you're out there and uh,
at that,
at the birthday party,
you are so fucked up about me lip to fuck all the birthday party stuff.
I,
first thing I did was Alpac as I looked at those things and I'm like,
wow,
those things look like a food source because they said they were from South
America.
So all of that picturing his boa constrictors and God knows what killing those
things,
you know,
or that like the Komodo Dragon,
this time he sat this stock in this giant bull looking thing and did the debt.
Those Komodo dragons,
they have such fucking shit breadth in their mouth is so full of bacteria that
if they,
all they gotta do is just nick an owl.
An animal just did 10 times its size.
It just need a bite it and then they just follow it around for three days is
that bacteria just slowly fucking kills the thing and I just wish the bull knew
that the second it was bit by that fucking dragon that it was over because then
you just,
you just turn around,
I'll blow.
You're not going to fucking eat me.
Right.
Just go over and kill the fucking thing.
Because the problem with those God damn reptiles and my issue with reptiles is
they don't have the d and chimpanzees is,
they don't have the decency to kill you before they start eating.
Yeah,
they don't know.
they don't like that thing.
Once you collapse it just walks up.
It has no feeling whatsoever,
you know,
which is why chimpanzees and human beings are the worst chimpanzees and human
beings.
The only people I've ever seen get off on the suffering of something else.
Like it actually excites him.
Uh,
I told you,
I think I saw that thing one time when they did for the longest time,
they didn't think chimpanzees,
monkeys,
eight other monkeys,
they disapproved that.
They found out it wasn't true.
And I saw these fucking chimpanzees catch this fucking smaller monkey.
All right.
And the,
he just stood on the thing's fucking back and with his fingers was digging flesh
out of its back as the other monkey screaming.
And the chip was getting off on a sec,
dude.
Like,
you know,
how fresh does it have to be?
Just snap it's little fucking neck and get on with it.
Um,
and ever since then,
I fucking hate chimpanzees.
I hate him.
I hate him as much as I love,
uh,
gorillas.
But having said that,
I don't want to see chimpanzees ever hurt though.
You know,
I,
you know,
although I wanted that bowl to fucking destroy that Komodo dragon has it just
kept falling around,
you know,
like some goddamn banker watching a fucking farmer working himself to death,
waiting to take over the land to sell to some other,
fuck.
All right,
Bill,
let's not get that dramatic.
Okay.
It's the wild.
Get Mad at God.
It created it.
Um,
it,
well,
I dunno if it's a fucking lady or not.
Yeah.
I've fucked up a human beings is big of pieces of shit that we are,
that uh,
we actually think God looks like us
and actually argue about what it's races or it's sex.
It's the stupidest shit ever.
MMM.
Okay.
Let me,
uh,
let me for the fun.
I have like 90 fucking window windows open and I'm getting rid of all of these,
except from my Brian Kest yoga videos.
I'm back into it.
I'm taking my power yogas watching these things.
You know what's funny is I,
in case anybody from his class,
here's this,
I own all of his shit on VHS.
I just don't have a fucking VCR anymore.
So I have purchased the things,
but I just can't play him soon.
I have to watch him on Youtube.
Um,
all right.
What am I,
where am I going here?
I fucking,
is it ever on the right email?
Come on.
You son of a bitch.
Why?
Why,
why?
Why are you doing this to me?
Loading as slow as humanly possible.
I have to hit pause.
All right,
my account.
Sign out.
Start over again.
There we go.
Come on.
Open Up.
You can do it.
All right.
I'm hitting pause.
This is pathetic.
I'll wait.
It's coming up.
Loading,
loading,
loading.
People.
Just try busy yourselves as I wait for this fucking thing to open up.
No,
I don't want the APP.
Oh my God.
All right.
Live reads here.
We all look.
Who's here?
Everybody et Cera.
Friends.
Old Zip.
Okay.
[inaudible]
talk about how important it is to have the right employees.
I'll tell you right now,
you know,
you only thing worse to have a right employees is the wrong employees.
Like what are you doing?
I don't know.
I guess I'm the wrong guy.
Hey,
get the fuck out here.
Wouldn't it be great?
Is it a service that help you to stop picking the wrong employee?
You know what I mean?
They hire some person who comes in ready to work,
you know,
not showing up with fuck me,
pumps and tits hanging out thinking that that's all they gotta do is just look
good,
right?
All Zip recruiter knew there was this mad away.
So they built a platform that finds you the right job.
Job can't candidates for you.
Ziprecruiter learns what you're looking for,
identifies people with the right experience and invites them to apply to your
job.
Uh,
those invitations have revolutionized how you find your next hire.
In fact,
80% of employers who post a job on ZipRecruiter get a qualified candidate
through the site in just one day.
This is also a great way to get a job right post you fucking resume on there and
zip.
Okay.
Doesn't stop there.
They even spotlight the strongest applications you receive,
so you never miss a great match.
That's the right candidates are out there.
Ziprecruiter is how you find them.
Businesses of all sizes,
trust,
sip.
Yeah.
For hiring needs pro.
Their hiring needs right now.
My listeners can try ZipRecruiter for free.
That's right.
Free.
Just go to ziprecruiter.com/birth at ziprecruiter.com/bar Huh?
SIP
[inaudible] dot com slash burns ZipRecruiter is the smartest way to hire.
I'm running out of ways to say that fucking word.
Oh,
look who's here in,
don't Cito.
Uh,
talk about how every man looks better in a suit.
Listen,
I love checking out the fellows,
but I'll tell you nothing gets my freckled motor running.
Like seeing a man in a well tailored suit.
The confidence,
the way the jacket blows in the breeze.
Indochino is the largest custom apparel company.
Guys love the wild selection of high quality fabrics in the options to
personalize all the details,
including the lapel jacket,
line lining,
monogram,
and much more.
Here's how it works.
Pick your fabric,
choose your customizations,
submit your measurements,
place your order and wait for it to arrive to arrive in three weeks or less.
You can shop online@indochino.com or visit any of their showrooms across North
America.
Yeah,
they have stores.
I don't think I've ever seen one this week.
My listeners can get any premium premium Indochino a suit for just 359 bucks.
That's indochino.com when entering Burr at checkout I n d o,
c h I n o.com.
That's over 50% off the regular price for a premium made to measure suit plus
shipping is free.
That's right.
indochino.com promo code bar for any premium suit for just 359 bucks plus free
shipping.
It's an incredible deal for a perfectly tailored suit.
There you go.
Three 59 bucks
and you're out the door.
You're out the fucking door.
Um,
all right.
Here's all the goddamn reads.
Here's what the fuck I was looking for.
God dammit.
Hey,
speaking of that,
am I in a Tulsa,
Oklahoma this weekend?
Speaking to southern accents?
Margaret,
I'll be down there on a over there in Tulsa,
Oklahoma.
The brain theater.
Yes,
I am March 30th Oh my God,
I love it.
What's today?
Today's the 26 let's see here.
That's Thursday,
Tuesday,
Wednesday,
Thursday,
Friday.
So this say I'm going to be,
um,
at the Brady theater,
Tulsa,
Oklahoma.
And then on March 30,
first I'm going to be down in San Antonio,
Texas,
right?
The stars at night are big and bright deep in the heart of Texas.
What do they have their,
what do they call that thing?
That little fucking river that you,
the riverwalk.
It's actually really relaxing,
you know,
then,
then you don't really ever have to get off and buy anything.
You just fucking sitting there floating around on a God damn boat.
That's going to be one of those weird flights where like it should only take me
like an hour to go from fucking Tulsa,
Oklahoma or 90 minutes to San Antonio.
But it's going to take the whole fucking day cause I'm up to like connect
through like Denver or some shit.
Um,
speaking of what she,
I got some shows coming up in Pittsburgh April 6th,
and for whatever fucking reason,
the only direct flight I can get out of La is a southwest flight.
I don't understand Philly and Pittsburgh back in the day,
the only direct flight from La to Philly was on us air.
I don't mind,
I don't mind southwest it until they start telling the jokes,
you know,
and just fucking,
it's so God damn obnoxious because nobody heckles him.
That's what's missing on a southwest flight.
Booing the jokes.
You have such a captive audience.
Everybody's afraid we're going to crash.
You know,
for some reason you'd think the steward or the stewardess actually is sliding
the plane so you don't want to give him shit.
Right.
Yeah.
Oh God.
That's when I wish I,
you know,
Patrice,
I could just fucking see him in that.
If he ever saw what those fucking people became.
Yeah.
He have had called.
Okay.
He definitely would have fucking heckled.
Um,
I just sit there and he's doing an anger and not even mad at the fucking steward
or stewardess is a,
which I still call them,
by the way.
I don't understand how the fuck that ever became offensive.
You know what I mean?
Or they feel like steward had
mmm.
Like,
I don't know,
come up.
It's to it.
Okay.
Why is,
let me look this up.
Why is
Stuart is offensive.
Okay,
I might be wrong.
Here's why.
Flight attendants don't like being called stewardesses.
All right.
Flight attendance.
Oh Man,
they've got an old fucking school one.
Look how hot they used to be.
Yeah.
I swear to God,
they must've fucking dropped the pay dramatically.
I don't know what they used to be.
Fucking gorgeous.
Unbelievable.
Yeah.
All right.
Flight.
But the food was way worse.
There's always a trade off,
right?
Um,
flight attendance have a job that holds a lot of prestige in the eyes of most
travelers.
Why?
What,
who?
There's a giant,
vague bullshit statement.
I think that used to be when the,
when they were beautiful women,
it seemed glamorous.
The whole thing.
The pilot seemed like a fucking borderline James Bond.
There's all these sexy women fucking walking around like wow.
They get to go to all of these places before everybody flew him all the time.
MMM.
People who actually used to dress up when they went on planes wearing suits and
women would,
would get all dolled up and shit.
You know,
this is before they treated you like a fucking animal though.
Then they started treating everybody like animals.
Now people walk in and on in the borderline pajamas anyways,
they get called a lot of different things while doing their jobs.
Waitress,
ma'am?
Hey,
you miss air hostess and Trolley Dolly.
Okay.
You know what?
I have well over a million fucking a frequent flier miles.
I've never heard anybody say waitress.
No one's ever said,
hey,
you air hostess.
Hey Trolley Dolly.
Can I get a fucking drink?
Come on.
I'm sure everybody has this story,
but come on.
I think pretty much everybody's been respectful is certainly after nine 11,
because then all the stewards and stewardesses,
all they have to say is,
uh,
why are you being hostile?
Do you not want to fly today?
Yeah.
MMM.
Anyways,
flight attendants have a job than Obama.
Okay.
Uh,
but one moniker that is pretty much gone out.
The emergency exit door is stewardess.
And here's why I love it.
This person just made up all of this other shit waitress,
ma'am.
Hey you.
Yeah,
trolley Dolly just made up all of that shit.
So they could get to the stewardess part.
All right.
I think it's safe to say that a strip tease ad for an airline like this one from
Braniff international airways below would not fly today.
Yeah.
A lot of things from back then wouldn't fly today.
Uh,
at least not in America.
Oh,
look at that.
Um,
but this type of ad,
which most would now consider objectifying towards women
yeah.
Was the only way to go in
the sex cells day.
Okay.
Sorry.
I was thinking about clicking on the video.
I was doing the math,
whether I could do that and not get in trouble because I'm advertising on this.
Sorry.
Let me go back to trying to read this.
Uh,
was the only way to go in the sex cells day of the early jet age.
Oh yeah.
Because they don't use sex to sell anything anymore.
A Braniff was hugely popular in its heyday.
Uh,
their flight attendants,
wars psychedelic trends from some of fashions,
top designers such as
Emilio Pucci.
Oh,
he fell off.
I never heard of that fucking guy.
Pacific southwest airlines was another airline ever.
I'm going to watch this fucking video.
Let's see what's going on here.
Uh,
Pacific southwest airlines was another airline press start to play with color of
course advertising.
And there's a bunch of sexy women winking at me and all this using sex to sell.
Yeah.
In 2018.
What is going on here?
Is this another ad?
This is an ad for Disneyland.
I'll,
you know what,
go fuck yourself.
Fuck this video.
And is this just clickbait?
Is that what I've done here?
Um,
was it another and can I take some something right now?
I guarantee you all these fucking hotties that were on this airline,
they weren't the ones that bitched.
It was ugly women that couldn't get the fucking job.
I am so sick of like,
there's certain jobs you should just be good.
Lucky.
Okay.
And as a fucking,
uh,
unsightly human being,
I feel like I can say this shit right.
Hey.
Yeah.
Can you walk into a restaurant?
You want to see somebody good looking,
you know,
hotel,
gym,
all of that Shit,
this fucking thing.
Now that you don't have to be good looking and you could be like,
uh,
you know,
overweight and all of that stuff is,
that's really not helping out fat people.
I can tell you that yes,
they're getting a job,
but they're still eating their way to a fucking early grave who doesn't want to
live.
It's sort of what you're doing is as much as you're giving them a job,
you're also in this roundabout way in each kind of doing this assisted suicide,
you're kind of a part of it,
right?
In a food sense.
I don't know what I'm talking about,
but I'm going to continue speaking.
Um,
Pacific southwest airlines was another airline that advertise the attractiveness
of its flight attendants.
They introduced the miniskirt in 1965 in our book,
long legs and short nights form a PSA flight attended Maryland trips said they
used to be a distinction between flight attendance and stewardesses.
Flight attendants were there for safety while stewardesses were there to be eye
candy,
flirt and served drinks.
Yeah,
that's your job.
The pilot passes out.
Do you know how to fly the fucking plane?
We'll then start waking it.
People,
this sweetheart,
um,
she noted stewardesses were not allowed to do pa announcements because nobody
could understand them.
I'll get this to get a little weird,
therefore,
let's face it.
They were,
they were along for the ride.
Now.
They weren't.
They were like,
they were serving drinks.
Maryland,
trich Schwartz contacted me to let me know that I had misunderstood a quote and
there was not a distinction between stewardesses and flight attendants.
They merely changed the job titles once more men joined the industry.
Yeah.
These were called stewards when she referred to stewardesses as they,
because she was one herself.
I miss interpreted that to mean that there were actually two different jobs,
so this guy really doesn't know what the fuck he's talking about.
Oh,
this woman,
what am I reading here?
I don't even know many modern and dare I say,
older flight attendants now considered stewardess a derogatory term towards
their profession and even their personal virtue because they take their job more
seriously.
That being there is simply too to serve as eye candy.
Okay.
All right.
I'm done with this fucking article.
I learned absolutely nothing other than the astounding lack of fucking research.
I mean,
I thought only I did that on my podcast,
this fucking person,
he literally,
his article,
rather than going back and correcting it,
he's fucking corrected himself.
Like he writes the article and I realized I fucked up and he's just continuing
on.
Yeah.
I mean,
at the,
at the end of the fucking day,
like this is just,
I think what really fucking happened was flying back then was glamorous.
Okay.
It was way more glamorous.
You got treated way more.
It was considered an,
an an an amazing luxury to be able to fly.
Now.
Everybody,
everybody fucking flies.
They,
Jamey in the back,
you know,
you have to pay for food.
I mean,
back then it was like coffee tea or me was,
was,
that was basically the,
uh,
the vibe back that,
you know what I mean?
And they're acting like,
yeah,
I dunno.
I Dunno what they're active,
they're,
they're acting like a that
yeah.
That there weren't some fucking women that that was an appealing job to,
not everybody has a dream.
Okay.
That's,
you know,
something that's,
maybe that's what's going on right now was fucking all of these medias is that
everybody's acting like they're fucking Joe Montana.
You know what I mean?
That they're like an Oscar winner.
Most of us would just put background that said,
where that guy in the fucking middle seat staring at the,
some woman serving them peanuts,
that is way out of their league that you'd never have the balls to talk to.
Not now.
Everybody's a winner according to Oprah.
You could do whatever you want.
It's going to be great.
All your dreams are going to come true.
Nobody's going to try to steal your ideas.
There's plenty of room for everybody.
Top of the mountain.
Um,
I,
that's just not the case.
I hate to say that.
If just go out and look at a mountain,
just look at the shape of this.
Plenty of room down the bottom.
There's a,
you know,
there's less,
but still a lot of room in the middle.
But as you keep going higher and higher,
you know,
it's,
I dunno,
I don't even know what I'm talking about.
I still don't understand why.
So basically
flight attendants wanted to,
okay,
they're still doing the same fucking job.
I Dunno.
Maybe now they,
they actually know CPR or some shit like that,
that took a couple of Mas classes.
Um,
but you know,
what are they,
what are they going to do?
You know what I mean?
I mean,
if like some terrorists go to take over the plane,
do they also have like Chinese stars that they're allowed to bring onto the
fucking plane?
Um,
please.
People,
I don't want to be called a comedian anymore.
I think that's offensive because people just feel like I'm going to have a
lampshade on my head.
I would now like to be called a,
uh,
a humor doctor,
doctor humor something,
or I'll come up with it.
I don't,
I don't want to,
um,
I think it's very sexist.
Just be called the comedian.
MMM.
I Dunno why.
You know,
other languages have male and female things.
I think that's the thing that made it my business to comedian.
They don't wanna be called a comedian.
We have a comedian coming to the stage.
Look,
why do you have to just make a distinction?
I Dunno.
Why did,
why did you,
I don't know.
I'm just,
can we get a gender neutral microphone was up the,
that's probably gonna be the next thing.
Maybe that microphones are shaped too much.
Like dicks.
They can have more
of a,
like a hermaphrodite style one.
You can have like a dick coming out of vagina.
Uh,
you know,
something may be like those old school Elvis once you get to have that and just
bad like a,
I don't know what you speak into.
Looks like a clip.
I don't know.
Is this technically even like still a podcast?
Let me just get to the questions this week that went nowhere by the way.
And I know a lot of it was ignorant and,
uh,
I think I stand by it.
Um,
all right,
let's get to the,
uh,
let's get to the questions here.
Jesus fucking Christ.
Yeah.
Become a pilot.
Yeah,
yeah.
Do that then.
Yeah.
Become a pilot.
Run an airline.
You want respect you that okay.
You fucking do that is be Ellie's police.
People on special teams all of a sudden want to be treated like quarterbacks.
I it,
it's just you're not a quarterback.
Sorry.
MMM.
Oh Shit.
The all things comedy festival is coming back again this year in,
uh,
is going to be a Comerica theater in Phoenix,
Arizona and October 26,
Jesus Christ.
Get your tickets early at ticket master.
Uh,
the Presale is Wednesday,
March 28th at 10:00 AM public on sale is Friday,
March 30th at 10:00 AM local time.
Both for both of those.
Uh,
and I will be posting the link on my Twitter and my Instagram and my Facebook.
Just an Internet dushoney all right,
Mr. Rogers movie.
Oh,
I love it.
It's a beautiful day in the neighborhood.
A Beautiful Day in the neighborhood.
Would you be mine?
Could you be mine?
I have always wanted,
I can't believe I remember this.
Have a neighbor just like you.
I've always wanted to live with you.
So let's make the most of this beautiful day.
E,
don't call them stewardesses and don't say,
hey column flight attendants make it seem like they have a master's degree.
Would you like some fucking peanuts?
You will respect me and my slacks.
Hello Mr Neighbors.
Mr. Rogers movie.
Hey there bill,
I'm writing to you here from Minneapolis and very much looking forward to your
upcoming show here.
You know Becca,
when I was a kid,
you know,
getting treated like shit motivated you to get a better job,
not demand that your you fucking be treated with respect that the low level that
you had attained in the job world.
Anyway,
I was wondering if you heard about the movie being made about Mr. Rogers
starring Tom Hanks is Fred Rogers.
Coincidentally a movie trailer was also just released for a new documentary
about Fred Rogers that just premiered at Sundance and it looks awesome.
I grew up watching Mr. Rogers as a kid and it's really refreshing to look back
at some of the clips that show what a grape,
one of a kind person he was.
Did you grow up watching Mr. RogersRogers' neighborhood?
Yes I did.
Mister McFeely speedy delivery.
And if so,
what were you or your thoughts about them making a movie about him?
Maybe you sh you have a different perspective now that you have a kid because it
seems like there's so much awful shit that kids are exposed to on TV and the
Internet.
And Mr. Rogers was a rare TV show,
which actually helps to become better human beings.
Last but not least,
would you consider auditioning for this shows?
Long time guest,
Mister McFeely?
I think you'd look hilarious in that mailman hat and went with the spectacles
and the mustache.
Thanks for being a great neighbor and go fuck yourself.
I absolutely would play mister McFeely.
Um,
I loved,
I loved Mr. Rogers when I was a kid.
I like sesame street better.
Um,
and there was something about him that did make me a little uncomfortable when I
was a kid.
I will admit that.
No,
you know what?
I didn't like lady Elaine and King Friday.
I liked the trolley when it went into the,
uh,
the make believe land or whatever.
But,
um,
I dunno,
Lady Lane and King Friday,
they just used to make me sick to my stomach.
They just weren't as funny and they didn't have the personality of like Ernie or
Grover Harry the cookie monster.
I mean,
there was just those who liked the guys guys have puppets over there on sesame
street.
I just thought it Mr. RogersRogers' neighborhood was,
it was just a little stiff.
But um,
I've,
I imagined that I learned a bunch of great lessons.
I was too young to understand like,
oh,
this guys tried to teach me how to be a better person.
You know,
it was just a kid watching the shit go.
Wouldn't that be cool if we had a trolley in our house and then you could get on
it and it go to a magical neighborhood and avoid king Friday and Lady Elaine,
she was fucking weird looking at too,
right.
I gotta look this up here.
Lady Elaine Lady
Lady.
How do you spell Elaine?
Oh yeah.
Yeah,
she was ugly.
Is dealing with them.
My God.
Lay off the booze
lady,
Elaine Fairchild.
I never knew the last name is a neighborhood.
And mischief maker.
And having learned from the wizard of Lou Povich off the uses or boomerang to
Marangu,
summa rang.
Oh my God,
I forgot about that.
To do things such as rearrange the neighborhood or turn it upside down.
She's credited with the discovery of planet Purpa,
Purpa,
which she found while flying in or something or other.
Well is it,
you know,
that would never happen.
Now that would be considered sexist.
Oh,
why?
Why does the woman have to be the bad person?
Well,
she's in a position of power.
Isn't that enough?
No.
Ah,
what are you doing?
Come on.
Um,
all right.
So I,
I think Tom Hanks is going to do a great job because he always does.
You know,
you look out,
we just said that like,
he's an upcoming actor rather than the two times back to back.
Best actor.
Um,
do I call him an actress now?
Is that progressive?
Should I not identify him by his gender?
I don't fucking know.
I don't know.
I don't know what,
what to do right now.
Um,
I think it'd be interesting if they actually get into his,
his whole life.
You know,
but if it's just Tom Hanks doing an episode of Mr. Rogers and then
I don't know.
I don't know what,
I don't fucking know.
I watch sports.
Why would you ask me about movies?
All right.
Linkedin business APP.
Dear Billy,
balloon head.
My girlfriend and I have been together,
his girlfriend,
one or two words.
There was two,
one word.
My girlfriend and I have been together for a year.
For the past two months.
She's been out of work
for two months.
It has been using this business app to get work online.
It has never bothered me as of revenue.
I think you said recently
as of revenue reverently me,
she has been getting notifications from the APP.
I don't know what any of that means.
I didn't think anything of it,
but I noticed that she had gotten a message in the middle of the night.
Oh,
as of recently.
This is a voice text.
Reverend Lee reverently me as of recently,
she has been getting notifications from the APP.
I didn't think anything of it.
Um,
but I've noticed that she has gotten messages,
gotten a message in the middle of the night.
I asked her about it and she always tells me that it's strictly professional.
And that is just business men seeking to employ.
Do you think that APP is just a cover up for meeting men?
She would meet on apps like Tinder.
Um,
I don't know dude,
but it doesn't sound like you fucking trust your,
uh,
your girlfriend,
which is definitely an issue.
So what you have done,
you have to figure out is if you don't trust her because had got saying she
shady or is it some,
some of your own shit that you brought because of a previous relationship or
possibly something that happened to you as a child when you were watching Mr.
Rogers
calling women's steward assists.
Um,
I dunno.
It's possible women are really good at fucking around,
which is why they don't get caught as much as guys do.
Guys,
you know,
guys are the worst,
we just fucking,
we get caught
anyways.
He wants,
I don't know.
I don't know what to tell you to do there.
So now you've got to start snooping and then if you get caught in your wrong
than what,
where does that leave you?
Just tell her it's making you feel insecure and you would just,
can you just,
you know,
and it's your issue.
Can you just see one of the texts next time it happens and then just say,
sorry,
I dunno.
I just love these oblige.
I was worried that somebody else was still a year.
Passions.
Talk your way out of it that way.
Does that work?
I don't know.
This is not professional advice.
He wants to get married.
I don't.
Hey,
built your phone of cynical humor and knowledge that I've admired for years.
Yo,
you are a fount.
Oh Jesus Christ.
So I wanted to ask some advice.
Hey,
this is not professional advice.
My boyfriend proposed two years ago after I said yes.
He said he wanted to keep it a secret since he hadn't met my parents yet,
except via Skype calls.
They live across the country by parents kept canceling their plans to visit last
minutes.
So he planned to visit them for this past Christmas where he would publicly
propose Jay's is,
Chris is the longest proposal ever.
I kept us to seek him for two years.
We only had two fights,
but each time he broke off the engagement,
only do apologize and make up the next day.
One month prior to the trip he says he wants to postpone and proposing due to
finances since we will be moving to another state after I graduate.
I understand.
Uh,
why spend five grand on a wedding.
One was soon need that to get a house while the next day he admitted.
The other reason is because I had gained weight after getting on birth control
and anxiety.
Man,
fuck this guy.
I'm getting a Master's in physics and I have a part time job.
So sorry if I couldn't hit the gym enough.
Uh,
well that's no excuse.
You should also fucking eat well and I'm not saying that about him and your,
your relations should do it for yourself because you really do not want the
health issues that fucking start earliest in your late thirties and into your
forties.
Um,
you know,
I've lost friends to heart attacks that look like they're in the same shape as
me,
but I don't,
you got to get checked up.
Um,
just cause you're busy.
This is what you do.
You fucking cook all your food on the weekend and the g you gotta make that up
fucking priority cause it's going to be stressful enough.
But anyways,
ice,
I still maintain at this point.
Fuck this guy.
Anyways,
that Christmas was so depressing,
but who could I talk to?
The engagement was a secret.
I told him being engaged was a joke.
I don't want to be on this rollercoaster anymore or ever again.
Now he started because he says marriage isn't,
it is important to him.
He does want to marry me.
Just not yet hot.
No thanks.
I'm good.
He said,
well we'll just revisit this later.
Your thoughts from one cynical ginger to another thanks to the left.
Yeah.
Fuck this guy.
Fuck this guy
does.
This is what,
this is what,
okay,
this guy's an asshole.
I want to postpone the engagement because you gain weight.
That's what the fuck you going to hit your wagon to fuck this guy.
Fuck that guy.
Um,
and you seem really strong and you,
you,
you get,
you know,
you're getting his master's degree in physics.
You could be out there designing roller coasters or whatever the fuck you're
going to be doing.
You don't need this guy.
By the way,
I watched this thing that I had recorded.
You know,
my wife's,
we got killed when it's stuff on the Dvr,
right?
Whatever the fuck you call it nowadays.
So we had to go back and erase a bunch of shit that I take.
I kept all my Superbowl highlights.
I,
and I kept the Patriots for Seattle and patriots first.
Atlanta had no problem or racing patriots versus eagles.
Um,
and I don't know where those patriots were as giants games went,
Geez.
Um,
Ethel Merman.
All right.
You want to talk about a fucking hilarious human being?
Uh,
I gotta find this fucking thing.
Ethel Merman.
She was all right.
We were watching this fucking thing on the JFK inauguration,
which was supposed to be broadcast by NBC.
And,
uh,
there was a horrific snow storm.
They were in this weird venue.
It was like Frank Sinatra,
Nat King Cole,
Ethel Merman.
Uh,
Milton Berle.
Who else?
Gene Kelly.
Harry Belafonte,
Ella Fitzgerald.
I mean it was crazy lineup and I'm Jimmy Duranti and all this shit.
This was like a,
it was a big deal.
This is the first time like marrying Hollywood and politics now where that's led
us is probably a bad thing.
But
MMM.
It was just on a watching all these performances and everything.
So watch an Ethel Merman and she's literally wearing just like this winter coat
during the performance because she went there for rehearsals and she got stuck
in the snow and couldn't get back to a hotel and she was a republican and still
saying to the president,
it rather than all these fucking Douche is today
[inaudible] you shit.
Right.
Did she put politics aside?
And she did it and as she was singing near just goes there.
She said something like that.
There's,
there's a fucking there right there,
there is a tough broad.
And I just started laughing and I said,
what do you mean?
She goes,
you could just see it.
She's,
she's been through it all bunch of asshole guys and she survived.
She's seen it all and blah blah.
So I look her up and of course neither was 100% right.
She'd been married like four times
and she was married one time for like three months to earn as Borg night.
And they got divorced.
All they did was argue and she,
one of the things she said was extreme cruelty.
So there's a quote,
I wish I could find the fucking thing.
Um,
let me,
I got to find,
cause I,
cause she it so perfectly.
This is,
you want to talk about somebody hilarious that you've loved to hang out with?
Um,
earnest.
I just put in Ethel Merman.
Earnest cunt.
Ernest Borgnine.
Ethel Merman.
There we go.
The classic Ethel Merman Story.
All right.
Of course,
this is going to be some douche turning it into an entire fucking
tire fucking blog.
Okay.
God Damn assholes.
Yeah.
So she,
she was in her brief marriage.
Mirman was on some fucking,
um,
she was on some fucking movie set and she came home.
She was all excited because the director had complimented her saying her,
she had the voice of like a 25 year old,
you know the face.
It's just like,
she was like 60,
all right,
35 year old face and a 35 year old figure any she said.
And then Ernest Borgnine said,
oh yeah,
he goes,
did he bring up your old content?
And she goes,
no,
he didn't mention you once.
Something like that.
I Dunno.
They find that this is,
this isn't written as well.
And what about your 65 year old cut?
And she said,
nobody mentioned you at all.
I've seen this thing written like five different ways.
She also did it.
She did a guest star on some set comp and they had a curse jar and she was in
the middle of whatever sketch they would do that she just stopped.
She goes,
what the hell is this going?
And then the star of the show was just like,
um,
Bethel,
you know,
my role that'll cost you a dollar and she just goes out.
What,
uh,
what would it cost me to tell you to go fuck yourself?
So Ethel Merman.
Ethel Merman is a,
I'm a new,
I'm a big fan of hers.
Um,
unfortunately she passed away a long time ago,
so you can't go out and have a drink with them,
but just seemed fucking hilarious.
All right.
Let me read the last goddamn question here so I can move on with my fucking
life.
MMM.
Why do I keep doing this?
I keep going away from my fucking the questions here.
This is unprecedented the amount of times I fucked this up and you guys have to
listen to me,
uh,
on precedent for this podcast,
I should say.
All right,
content.
Here's the last one.
The last one
is a jealous boyfriend.
I love that the women have finally right now.
All right.
Hello,
Bill Barr.
I really love your podcast.
Thank you.
When I was wondering what your thoughts on a situation I am going through.
This is my first serious relationship.
My boyfriend and I just moved in about four months ago.
I have all,
I have always fucking now that he's been over protective and jealous,
however I it started to progress more and more.
Oh,
get out,
get out.
I trust him that he's not cheating on me.
Of course like many other women,
I can be self conscious and think that maybe he could stray or do better,
but I've never once accused them of cheating on me.
Not once,
however he has caused me
what he has caused me of cheating on.
He's accused do,
these are all voice texts he has caused me of cheating on him.
He's accused me of cheating on him multiple times.
The worst case of when should have been of which he made accusations,
uh,
was fairly recently.
I just got a full,
a new full time job.
I was only working part time minimum wage job,
which I'm very excited about that,
this full time job.
Um,
so that he's not the only one working.
I feel like I can contribute now.
However,
he started accusing me of cheating on him with someone at work,
even though there is no evidence.
He even started accusing me of cheating on him with his own cousin.
He's the one that helped me get the job is actually of 10 dump this guy.
His accusations are not just him speaking,
but yelling,
hitting walls and scaring me to the point like he might get violent.
Ah,
right.
Here's what should do.
Okay.
Put a deposit down on another fucking apartment.
One day when he goes to work,
you take a fucking sick day,
all right?
You get a friend yet clear all your shit out of there.
Yeah.
Fuck this guy.
All right?
You don't want to be anywhere near this guy.
You don't want to be around this guy when you break up with him,
he seems like a,
I don't like any of this.
Uh,
he doesn't even want me to wear shorts and we live in this area that gets hot.
I am not the type of person to show a lot of skins.
However,
when it's hot,
I would like to wear shorts.
You see what's going on here?
Sky's taken over your whole life.
I'm just wondering if this,
if his thoughts
that me wearing shorts is disrespectful to him to the point he is just uh,
wait a minute.
I'm just wondering if his thoughts that me wearing shorts as different,
as disrespectful to him to the point is justified breaking up with me over this.
I am not sure where to draw the line.
Oh,
you should have drawn the line of while ago.
Let me ask you this.
If any girlfriend you had was telling you this story,
you would be like,
get the fuck out.
Right.
I really believe that.
I love and care about him.
That's the problem.
However,
when he does,
when love,
when does love turn into more of an obsession?
Also,
what is considered an abusive or unhealthy relationship?
I would say this.
I would really like to know your thoughts.
You are straight up and I believe you'll be able to give some good advice,
especially since you will not have real bias since you don't know us.
Thank you.
Yeah,
you should get the files as far as your version.
What's going on?
You should
get the fuck out of here.
Okay.
Just the fact that he's choosing you a cheating on him.
Um,
and what's your,
what his cousin,
which is fucking weird.
And then yelling and hitting the walls.
I mean,
you're already out.
You're already gone.
It should be gone.
And now,
uh,
the fact that he's telling you what you can and can't wear,
fuck this guy.
So
the problem is,
is moved in with the guy.
So if you break up with the guy,
what are you going to go into another room?
And then you gotta worry about this guy,
you know,
doing God knows what.
Um,
do you have any male friends?
Do you have a brother?
Somebody,
you know,
they can help protect you when you get your shit out of there?
I would get another fuck.
I,
I mean,
this is a type of situation.
I wouldn't fuck you pride.
I would move back in with my parents if I had to and drive longer to work.
Get the fuck out of that.
MMM.
And,
uh,
I'd be,
it's easiest break up ever as far as the reasons.
Uh,
I dunno,
cause you don't trust me because you think I'm fucking your cousin to the
points.
You're a acting like Jeff Goldbloom in the fly and start punching the goddamn
door jams out.
Oh.
And by the way,
it's 90 degrees out and I can't wear shorts because you and your fragile ego
can't fucking handle it.
And I wouldn't say it this way because this guy sounds like a lunatic.
Um,
I dunno what,
what could you say that would just make this guy go away?
Just say,
ah,
you know,
I just decided that I want to get really fat and wear shorts and I didn't want
to put you through that.
I don't know what to tell you,
but I would get out of this and when somebody is violent like this,
okay.
Uh,
I would be concerned about your own safety.
So like I said,
I would take a,
um,
yeah,
this is what you do.
All right.
Yeah,
I figured you,
you sound like you're young,
so you probably don't have that much shit.
So,
uh,
I would just,
whatever your friend is that's going to help you move up,
you put the boxes together over her house.
Okay.
All right.
And then bomp.
Bomp bomp bomp bomp bomp you fucking go in there.
All right.
You just act like you go into work and then you don't fucking go to work.
Okay.
Yeah.
And uh,
I would even tell you boss,
just say,
listen,
I am living with a guy I have to break up with and I'm afraid he's going to get
violent.
So he's at work today.
Uh,
I'm going to act like I'm going to work and I'm going to clear my shit out of
that.
And I think you should be fine.
And then you guys fucking,
and he'd probably be like,
you want some fucking help?
You know,
cause he's a good dude.
And then also maybe,
maybe he's trying to fuck him.
Wait a minute.
Maybe your boyfriend's actually making a good point.
No,
I'm kidding.
Go in there and I would just clear all your fucking shit out and uh,
I would fucking,
yeah.
And I would go live somewhere else.
And,
uh,
then I would have one last conversation with this guy and I would change my cell
phone number and that's it.
And,
uh,
I don't know,
depending on where the fuck you live,
maybe you can just,
he won't be able to find you.
But uh,
yeah,
this is just,
this is good.
This is the beginning.
This has the beginnings of someone that's going to stalk you and possibly do
something fucking horrible.
Fuck this guy.
All right.
I wish my wife was here to hear this God damn email she's always talking about,
you know,
I'll fucking difficult a person.
I am,
you know,
I'm going to fucking print this email out and put it on her,
her side of the bed,
on the pillow.
I shouldn't be making jokes like this.
Yeah,
I would get the fuck out of it.
Uh,
and that's it.
And I would,
uh,
go find love with somebody that's excited that she got a new job,
that you're going to be participating and that,
uh,
and let you wear shorts when it's hot out.
There you go,
everybody.
That's the podcast for this week.
Oh,
go fuck yourselves.
And I'll check.
Yeah.
On,
uh,
on Thursday.
Kerryn congratulations to the Ferrari team for winning.
The next one is,
I believe in Bahrain or something like that,
and then they go to fucking Singapore.
All right,
I'll see you.